hi i'm alex greer with the ibm cloud
team today i want to talk about ibm
cloud secrets manager but before i get
into it don't forget to hit that
subscribe button
as enterprises build more microservices
and become globally distributed
securing application secret data becomes
much more complex
as we saw before in my previous video
secrets management services enable the
secure management
of digital credentials that ultimately
allow for entities to securely interact
with services
ibm cloud secrets manager is a service
based on open source hashicorp fault
designed to securely manage the
lifecycle of secrets such as im api keys
user credentials or different forms of
arbitrary text
this allows it security leaders to dream
big about their cloud native application
future
without being concerned about data
breaches from mismanaged credentials
or losing velocity in their developer
operations while securing secrets
secrets manager centralizes the
experience of generating
storing rotating and revoking multiple
types of secrets
from a single pane of glass integrations
with other services such as your private
catalogs and ibm cloud
and enabling the retrieval of your
secrets and contacts when you need them
streamline your workflows through
leasing it even allows for you to give
an application or a team member
temporary access to a service to
complete their respective tasks
as a managed service secrets manager
offers much
of the same benefit of an on-premise
deployment of vault without the hassle
of having to maintain its tricky
operators
or manage ultimately operate its
underlying infrastructure
this allows you to keep your desired
security posture at scale
while we take care of the rest a
critical element of secrets manager that
makes it so powerful
is its unique trust model built for
enterprises that have very little
tolerance for any sort of data
vulnerability
beneath the velocity provided by the
cloud
this model starts by allowing you to
seal your vault and encrypt all of your
hosted secrets
within your own root encryption key for
example
one of your existing fips compliance
keys from
ibm keeper tech could do this giving you
ownership of your data
next your data is protected in transit
through tls
your vault as well as the ui and apis
that you use to interact with it
are all single tenant meaning your data
is
isolated in your own dedicated silo and
doesn't rely on any shared components
and should you decide to delete your
instance you have the peace of mind that
your data
is cryptographically deleted thanks for
listening to this introduction
of the ibm cloud secrets manager to get
started with improving the security of
your secrets
come check us out in the ibm cloud
catalog
you